utilisez d'une part la rade unique est
une activité sportive mais ça peut être
aussi une activité culturelle une
activité sociale
c'est un outil d'éducation d'animation
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire en
l'associant au cerf-volant
pourquoi parce que premièrement en ce
moment ce fut la période des
cerfs-volants la première génération
s'en souvient largement où les enfants
on les trouvait à la tête des collines
là où il y avait du vent et les enfants
de ce type au cas les jeunes de cette
époque là avait la 18 lisez cette force
éolienne pour pouvoir s'amuser s'amuser
à travers ce cerf-volant ce petit
élément qui faisait entrer en ligne de
compte la créativité et les
connaissances mathématiques notamment
parce que c'est les cerfs-volants était
mal fait il ne pouvait pas monter et à
voir se donner du plaisir à voir
montrent effectivement ce petit cerveau
lent d'ailleurs avec sa basse à ça qu
dans l'espace dans l'air et c'était la
période des cerfs-volants donc nous
voulons profiter de de cette situation
de ce pays au-delà pour se remémorer on
est au goût du jour
le cerf-volant qui fut un élément je
dirais presque incontournable de notre
patrimoine
martiniquais entier parce que le
cerf-volant il n'est pas seulement
propre à la martinique mais aussi cet
élément qu'on trouve dans le monde et
notamment en chine
alors vous avez choisi la ville du
vauclin un choix particulier c'est un
choix pas tout à fait particulier mais
le savons que c'est difficile de te dis
va parce que c'est l'un des cerveaux
liste qui sera avec nous avec jeu c'est
plutôt si désiré s'il m'a conseillé cet
espace le ciel de de vos clics vauquelin
parce que nous nous trouvons ce côté
atlantique où le vent est régulier nous
avons réalisé tout à fait régulier qui
nous pour en bénéficier vous faire
monter les cerfs-volants et puis aussi à
le support est l'accompagnement la
collaboration d'une association qui
s'appelle alliance tradition qui
contribue avec nous pour faire en sorte
que la fed se réunissent et que tous
nous ayons ce dimanche là les pieds sous
terre mais l'athlète unis vous tenez
vers le ciel tout à fait alors quel est
l'objectif qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'un
président peut attendre de cette
manifestation un président à temps là
cette manifestation qui lance un appel
aux parents qui lance pour pouvoir
emmener leurs enfants qui lancent un
appel aux amoureux de la création du
cerf-volant parce que ça comme je les
dis précédemment s'en remettra en ligne
de compte nos connaissances
mathématiques premiers mois deuxièmement
au niveau des enfants la créativité le
plaisir de fabriquer le plaisir
d'imaginer le plaisir d'associer les
couleurs et où est aussi retrouver cette
maîtrise la ce réflexe là pour pouvoir
faire monter nos cerveaux lents et je
pense que se joue là le ciel sera multi
couleurs parce que je suis persuadé que
nous aurons pas mal de cerf-volant est
aussi l'occasion de rencontres nos
grands cerfs volistes plus temps et des
vies civiles qui se fera un réel plaisir
de transmettre leurs connaissances au
niveau de la fabrication de petits
objets très agréable et aussi qui à
travers lequel nous pouvons lancer le
défi d'ailleurs ce sera l'occasion de
mettre de côté les parents de l'autre
les enfants pour savoir
laquelle déduit aura le meilleur
maîtrise pour faire monter au plus haut
merci aux volailles et comme disait la
chanson survolant voulait voler